[Musique]
vachement bon ce [ __ ] avance avance
avance avant sa manche en 40 ans
votons toi c'est toi qui nous a donné
arrête de dire n'importe quoi c'est fou
c'est toi au moins tu fous là alors toi
que tu fous là tu fous là
arrêtes ta vie de ma mère avec le recul
j'ai entendu qu'on ceinture est descendu
voir une heure après tu viens me ramener
sergio mora temps mort et bd condé
partout je sais pas quoi faire
tu sais pas où les gens remonter me
cacher je restais quelques trucs énormes
il s'est passé quoi de mes camps scouts
ils nous attendaient cycliste un [ __ ]
ça on verra après sequana on va mettre
ça dans la cité il ya des flics partout
il faut qu'on se casse
regarde moi regarde
ratant deux ans qu'il est en train de se
brider condé sur aisne manu et laisse
tomber
la prochaine fois merci pour l'accueil
et prend le ballon du petit toit baisse
de titi des champs d'ogm merde on pousse
fort boyard s étaient d'une sarkissian
de 30 quand les troupes
on doit la regarder changé la donne et
brown garde ses beautés fournisseur
historique
[Applaudissements]
et
120 me go ça fait plaisir de voir qu'il
est bien trop bas doit laver avec tu
passerais par là lâche ça t'as rien à
branler la dégage la singer papa ou été
gâchée parce que tu sais qui vous a tiré
dessus
qu'est ce que ça peut être pas besoin de
moi m'a nommé j'ai entendu les rumeurs
je sais que c'est pas toi mais j'ai
besoin de savoir qui c'est tu as
toujours dit pour vivre et blogueur
n'est pas content tu avais raison
alors casse-toi
et moi bosser avec moi ouais c'est ça
arrête tes conneries mais je peux donner
les dates de ce voyage à conakry ces
contacts les quantités de drogue achetée
je peux dans l'hôtel où il est descendu
l'intercontinental je peux donner
l'adresse de la maison est accroché au
portugal en attendant la can je continue
encore là il m'a n'aurait jamais bossé
avec des fruits c'est toi qui nous a
suivis et nous a mis sur écoute et où il
s'est fait serrer par les douanes ayant
un nom sur votre petit trafic amsterdam
il est venu le supplier de mais qu'est
ce que tu crois toi
vous êtes tous prêts à donner votre mère
pour sauver votre qu al imran toi tous
les autres c'est pareil vient expliquer
la ville toile aura des fils de [ __ ]
madonna je viens pas t'expliquer la vie
juin propose un marché
gerry et moi me devais livrer de la coco
reyes apparemment il était ok c'est bien
savoir ce qui s'est passé un combat sur
moi ces balises ne sais pas qui serait
d'un mariage sont montés normale 7/8 ans
si tu reviens c'est
vous la connaissez cette bande c'est pas
une bombe
et comme des mecs qui bossent ensemble
oui monde et qu ils vont là où il ya du
fric bras couchite cook
ils ont bien compris monde dans lequel
on vit
[Musique]
parce que tu sais qui vous a tiré dessus
papa voulait dégager sans moi témoins 29
tous ceux qui parlent de trois disent
que c'est toi qui a fait mal
il faut que tu trouves qui a fait ça
genou qui ne pourra pas faire taire les
rumeurs médias me on a grandi au même
endroit a pas de même qu'à toi ça va pas
forcément dire qu'on est m
je te promets je vais manger
[Musique]
aussi dis-moi ce que tu attends moi je
le fais
tu continues à la clé tu dis là car des
choses à toi tout dans le bourg de
terrain
at elle sait jouer avec les genres
[Musique]